a fuel shortage is getting worse across
the southeast but
it should end soon drivers have been
lining up at gas stations for days
since a cyber attack shut down the main
pipeline for the east coast well this
morning
the colonial pipeline is open again our
lead national correspondent david begno
is outside a colonial fuel facility in
woodbridge township new jersey david
good morning good morning we are right
near the finish line vlad it starts down
in houston comes up all the way to new
jersey where we are the fuel
is coming that is the announcement this
morning and boy doesn't it sound good
haven't we all seen
how hackers can disrupt things drive up
the price of gas cause panic at the
pumps
now that it's restarted how long should
it take to get back to normal three
maybe five days but it's back up and
running
all of that panic at the pump seem to be
reaching a tipping point
at gas stations across the southeast
it's like the toilet paper fiasco all
over again
according to gas buddy north carolina is
getting hit the hardest
74 of its stations are facing outages
half of the stations are out in georgia
and it's even higher in south carolina
and virginia there is fuel available
it's just when everybody's buying it at
the same time due to hysteria
then it creates gaps in the supply chain
and that's just what we're seeing here
for now it appears the impending crisis
is nearing an end
although not a quick one the supply
itself
is not really at issue here kent moores
is the executive
chair of the energy capital research
group these are going to be local
inabilities to move
supply to where the demand is when the
demand hits
and that's going to take about 48 hours
colonial pipeline has declined to say
whether it paid a ransom to the hackers
in a statement the company said safety
was its primary focus
and that it would conduct a
comprehensive series of pipeline safety
assessments
former fbi deputy director and cyber
security expert sean joyce
says private companies need to work
together with the federal government to
combat
future attacks and the private sector
companies are really
left to defend themselves and on some of
these sophisticated adversaries like
nation states and
organized crime groups that is a very
difficult proposition
you know yesterday the president signed
an executive order to strengthen cyber
security defenses in this country
but it does not include privately run
infrastructure like oil and gas
companies and
gail 80 percent of the energy
infrastructure in this country is
privately run so you got to wonder how
this executive order is
going to make much of a difference at
this point yeah very good question david
bagno thank you